[Música]
bienvenidos a enlace conosur desde
uruguay en el programa del día de hoy
hablaremos sobre el desarrollo
tecnológico del país que ha generado la
inversión de gigantes mundiales como
google también les presentaremos como
uruguay se adaptó rápidamente a la
creciente tendencia del transporte
eléctrico para atraer la industria
automotriz
además conversaremos sobre la ola
emigratoria de argentinos que han
llegado a uruguay en los últimos dos
años en búsqueda de una mejor calidad de
vida
tras décadas de esfuerzo público-privado
uruguay logró convertirse en un hub
tecnológico de nivel internacional
desarrollando la infraestructura
necesaria y ofreciendo personal
calificado como mencionábamos esto
permitió que google decidiera invertir
en el país
recientemente google anunció la
construcción de un nuevo cable submarino
que unirá uruguay con eeuu y manifestó
la intención de un centro de datos que
implicará una inversión de 100 millones
de dólares y será el segundo en américa
latina y el 14º que la internacional
tiene en todo el mundo los parques
tecnológicos instalados dentro de zonas
francas han sido un incentivo importante
para que se concreten estas inversiones
que a los extranjeros les dan beneficios
que no lo pueden tener otro lado un
beneficio un impuesto a la renta que
pagan muy poco el 12% solamente se
pueden importar en un computador
mientras lucen aquí no lo tiene no
tienen que pagar ningún impuesto este
pueden remitir dinero fuera o recibir
dinero fuera y no hay ningún problema
pero todo eso entonces muy fácil operar
cuando unos terneros internacionales o
perder de una zona franca de uruguay
uruguay siendo el país más pequeño de
américa del sur y sin producción de
petróleo abastece el 98 por ciento de su
energía eléctrica con fuentes renovables
como la eólica y la hidroeléctrica e
incluso exporta a brasil estas
condiciones son terreno fértil para el
desarrollo del transporte eléctrico una
modalidad que crece a nivel mundial como
una vía para disminuir la contaminación
en la capital del país la flota de autos
eléctricos es cada vez más grande y
sigue en aumento y aunque al principio
de generó una importación de autos de
alta gama pronto comenzó a extenderse a
opciones más accesibles como motos
bicicletas y autos medianos uruguay
cuenta con una de las densidades de
cargadores para automóviles eléctricos
más altas del mundo la distancia máxima
entre cargadores es de menos de 100
kilómetros es justamente la matriz
energética y los incentivos impositivos
que uruguay otorga al transporte
eléctrico lo que lo puso en la mira de
las compañías automotrices
internacionales
uruguay y se distingue en en la región
todas y en el mundo es de los 5 países
que tienen más del 95 por ciento de su
generación de fuentes renovables segundo
punto es la red de cargadores en la red
pública de cargadores hay una fase 1
de cargadores instalados por usted y
hasta la fase 2 que está en todo el
territorio nacional con cargadores de
corriente alterna y ya está la
licitación de la fase 3 que van a ser en
distintos puntos de las rutas nacionales
cargadores de corriente continua que
hace que la carga sea muchísimo más
rápida estamos hablando de cargas de 15
minutos
referentes de diversas industrias
señalan que uruguay a nivel
internacional es visto como un país
cumplidor de reglas claras que las
mantiene pese a los cambios de gobierno
y esto lo posiciona como un muy lugar
donde invertir en los últimos dos años
ha aumentado el número de extranjeros
que han decidido venir a vivir al país e
incluso trasladar sus empresas aquí
muchos de ellos vecinos argentinos
históricamente uruguay ha recibido
migración de argentinas por la belleza
tranquilidad y seguridad charrúa el
presidente luis lacalle pou flexibilizó
los requisitos para una serie de
beneficios fiscales muy atractivos para
los vecinos del río de la plata' la
actual situación de la economía en
argentina y las restricciones por la
pandemia han hecho que muchos ciudadanos
del país austral emigran en búsqueda de
estabilidad económica y calidad de vida
esta migración también ha beneficiado a
uruguay porque el mercado inmobiliario y
la educación han crecido es muy
interesante porque el gobierno de
lacalle pou también ha y dio en el clavo
y sacó una ley muy interesante que la 19
1904 en septiembre del 2020 justamente
para atraer nuevos inversores bajo lo
que se requería el mínimo requerido para
lograr la residencia fiscal de un millón
setecientos mil dólares de inversión en
inmuebles a 380 mil dólares también bajo
el tiempo que uno tiene que permanecer
en uruguay de 183 días a 60 días
que no tienen por qué ser corridos pues
pueden ser alternados y por otra parte
también beneficio con un tag holiday de
10 años no solamente a los nuevos
residentes sino a los que ya tenían la
residencia fiscal de 5 años de
textualidad y que pasó a 10 años así que
ese paquete de medidas realmente
resultaron super atractivas y está
haciendo que el año pasado se batió un
récord de personas que vayan a vivir
uruguay y todo esto indica de que va a
seguir siendo así el presidente uruguayo
luis lacalle pou manifestó su intención
de acoger a 100.000 extranjeros durante
su mandato aunque la cifra está lejos de
alcanzarse en los últimos dos años se
quintuplicaron las solicitudes de
residencia de unas 11 mil personas ya la
obtuvieron llegamos así al final de
enlace conosur desde uruguay sigan con
nuestra programación en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom